-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
And this is "Late Night."
How's everybody doing tonight?
That is so wonderful to hear
Let's get to the news.
Federal agents today
raided the home of Rudy Giuliani
as part of an investigation into
whether he broke lobbying laws
as President Trump's
personal lawyer.
The agents gained access to hi
home using a "no-neck" warrant
But lucky for Rudy, wives can'
testify against their cousins.
President Biden tonight
delivered his first addres
to a joint session of Congress
before a crowd
of just 200 people
due to COVID concerns.
Just 200 people?
The last time I was in a crowd
of just 200 people,
I didn't even know
how to bake bread yet.
Tomorrow will be President
Biden's 100th day in office,
and say what you will --
you got to admire Q's patience
According to a newly release
court ruling,
the FBI is allowed to continue
surveilling Americans' private
e-mails without a warrant,
and they are under no obligation
to tell you
if they see a couch they like.
President Biden
reportedly estimates
that he has taken more tha
8,000 round trips on Amtra
in the last 50 years.
Yet it feels even more than that
said the guy he sits next to
"Hey, Dave!"
"Oh, son of a gun."
"The New York Times"
announced this week
that it will no longer
use the phrase "op-ed"
and will instead use
"editorials" or "guest essays,
while "USA Today" announced it's
doing away with words entirely
After a five-year
restoration process,
England's Big Ben clock
is expected to chime again
next year,
but I don't think people
are gonna like the update.
[ Cuckoo clock chimes ]
The CDC recently released
updated guidance
for camps that plan
to reopen this summer,
like you can't wear the same
underwear for a week, Todd
Two 90-year-olds
in New Jersey
recently defied
coronavirus lockdown rules
in their retirement communit
in order to sneak into
each other's apartments.
Love will find a way.
It might not find its way back
but love will find a way.
"Mortimer, what are you doin
out here?"
"I was [bleep]"
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
the average pet owner said the
have four so-called mini-panic
about their animal per week,
while some pet owners
have so-called Major panic
"Major, get the prime minister's
head out of your mouth!
Hey, Dave!"
"Oh, son of a gun."
"Got to tell you about wha
happened to Major this week.
"Uh-huh."
A man was arrested at New York's
JFK Airport on Monday
after allegedly smuggling
35 live finches
for high-stakes
singing contests.
He's being held for questioning,
and most of the questions
are about
the high-stakes
singing contests.
And finally,
according to a new survey,
nearly 50% of people said that
they experienced déjàà vu,
and, according to
a follow-up survey,
100% of people said they did
And that was a monologue.